The second part of CPU virtualization, which
is common to both full and para-virtualized
environments, is being able to deliver events
to the parent guest operating system. And these
events are events that are generated by a process that belongs to the guest
operating system, currently executing On the CPU.
Let's see what is happening to this process,
when it is executing on the CPU. Once this process has been scheduled
on the CPU, during its normal program execution, everything should
be happening on hardware speech, what is that mean? Well. The process
is going to generate virtual addresses that has to be translated to
machine page addresses. And we talked at
length about how the hypervisor can ensure that the virtual address translation
to the machine page address. Can be done at hardware speeds by clever tricks
in the hypervisor and or the guest operating system. In a fully virtualized
environment, the hypervisor is responsible for ensuring
that the virtual address gets translated directly
to the machine address. With all the
intervention of the guest operating system. And para-virtualized
environment once again with cooperation between the guest
and the hypervisor, we can ensure that the
page table that is used for translating virtual
address to physical addresses is something that had
been installed. On behalf of the guest operating
system, by the hypervisor so that the translation
can happen at hardware speeds. And is the most crucial part of ensuring
good performance for the currently executing,
process in a virtualized environment. All address
translations. I dealt with. That's why I kept harping on the fact that
virtual memory, managing the virtual memory, is
the thorny issue in a virtualized setting.
So we know that this is in good hands,
we know how to handle that. Let's look at other
things that can happen to this process during the course
of its execution. One thing that this process may do.
Is execute a system call. For instance, it might want
to open a file. And that's really a call into
the guest operating system. That's something that this process may
do. Another thing that can happen to this process is
that it can incur a page fault. Not all of. The virtual address piece of the
process is going to be in the machine memory.
And therefore if some virtual page cannot be translated,
then it's going to result in a page fault.
Or the process may throw an exception. For
instance, it might do something silly like divide
by zero which can result in an exception And
lastly, though no fault of this process, there
could be an external interrupt when this process
is executing. So these are the kind of
discontinuities, these are called program discontinuities, that is, affecting
the normal execution of this process. And the
first three things that I mentioned, syscall, page
fault, and exceptions, are due to this process
in some shape or form. But the fourth one,
the external interrupt is something that is
happening asynchronously and unbeknownst to what this
process intended to do while running on
the processor. And all of these continuities
have to be passed up, by the hypervisor to the guest operating system. So
the common issue. To both full and
para virtualized environment, is that all such program
disk continuities for the currently running process
have to be passed up to the parent
guest operating system by the hypervisor. Whether it
is a para virtualized or a fully virtualized
operating system. Nothing special needs to be done
in the guest operating system for fielding these
events from the hypervisor. because all of these
events are going to be packaged as software
interrupts by the hypervisor and delivered to the
guest operating system. Any operating system knows how
to handle interrupts. So all the hypervisor has
to do. Is to package these events as software
interrupts, and pass it up to the guest
operating system. There are some quirks of the architecture
that may get in the way and the
hypervisor may have to deal with that. Recall that
syscalls and page faults and exceptions. Or all things that need to be handled
by the guest operating system. So it
probably has entry points in it, for leading
with all these kinds of program list continuities. Now some of the things that
the guest operating system may have to
do to deal with these. Program discontinuities may
require the guest operating system to have privileged
access to the CPU. That is, certain instructions
of the processor can only be executed in
the kernel mode, or the privileged mode. But
recall that the guest operating system itself Is
not running in the privileged mode. It is
above the red line, which means it has
no more privilege than a normal user-level process.
This is a problem, especially in a
fully virtualized environment. Because the fully virtualized
environment, the guest operating system has no
knowledge that it does not have the privileges.
So when it tries to execute some
instruction, that can be executed only in publish
mode, the expectation is that. It'll trap,
get in the hypervisor, and the hypervisor will
then do the work that the fully
virtualized guest operating system was intending to do.
But here is where the quirks of
the architecture come into play. Because unfortunately, some
privileged instructions fail silently in some architectures
when they're executed at the user level. And
this is a problem for the fully virtualized
environment. Where the binary is unchanged. In the
paravirtualized environment, because we know that the paravirtualized guest
is not running on bare metal, we know that
it does not have the same privilege as the
hypervisor. And therefore, we can collaboratively make sure that
anything that the guest has to do in privileged
mode. It can take the help of the hypervisor
to do it. But in a fully virtualized setting,
the guest has no knowledge. So the only mechanism
that will save the day, is if the
guest tries to execute a privileged instruction, it'll
trap into the hypervisor, and the hypervisor can
do the necessary thing. However, because some instructions
when executed at the user level. Even though
they are privileged instructions. They don't trap, but
fail silently and that can be a problem.
This happens in older versions of Access Architecture
for privilege instructions, executed in user mode. Therefore, the hypervisor has
to be intimately aware of the quirks of the hardware, and ensure
that there is workaround such quirks. Specifically, in a fully virtualized
setting, the hypervisor has to look at the unchanged binary
of the operating system, and look for Places where
these quarks may surface and do binary rewriting in
order to catch those instructions when and if
they're executed on the CPU. Having said that, I should mention that. Newer
versions of Intel's architecture and AMD architecture for the
x86 constructions have included virtualization support so
that these kinds of problems don't occur. As
a result of servicing the events that are
delivered with a hypervisor, the guest may have
to do certain things. Which may result in communication
back to the hypervisor. In the case of
a fully virtualized environment, communication from the guest
to the hypervisor is always implicit via traps.
For example, as a result of page four servicing,
the guest may try to install a new entry
into the page table. When it tries to do
that, that's a trap that will come in to
the hypervisor and the hypervisor will take the appropriate
action. In a pair of a virtualized environment the communication from the guest
to the hypervisor is explicit, so that API's that the hypervisor supports
for the guest OS to communicate back to the hypervisor. What maybe
reasons for that? Well. We talked about memory
management done by the guest operating system in a
pair of virtualized environment such as [UNKNOWN] where
the guest operating system may have to tell the
hypervisor, here is a page table entry. Please
install it in the page table for me. So
that is the kind of communication that may have
to come back from the guest operating system down
to the hypevisor.